I
it's gone you both know what's at stake
here there is a lot left to take a
bloody shot what do you say about a man
like that three months ago you lost the
drive containing the identity of every
agent embedded in terrorist
organizations across the globe
double-oh-seven reporting for duty where
the hell have you been enjoying death I
only have one question why not stay dead
there's no shame in saying you've lost
the stuff
they weren't targeting her they wanted
her to see it welcome to the new mi6 I'm
a quartermaster you must be joking
walther ppk s landed a metre short it's
been coded to your palm prints only you
can fire it less of a random killing
three more of a personal statement Q
double oh seven I want to meet your
employer how much do you know but fear
not like this not like here just look at
you chasing spies England and my sakes
she send you after me know when you're
not ready know when you would likely die
mommy was very bad the two survivors
this is washing made us everybody needs
a hobby so what's yours resurrection